un bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce jeudi 4 mars
[Musique]
confinement confirmer le week-end pour
le parquet les trois départements joanes
la liste de ceux vigilance renforcée
hautes-alpes haine et l'aube la campagne
vaccinale et son accélération au coeur
des annonces de jean castex et l'olivier
véran la vaccination possible en
pharmacie est désormais à compter de la
semaine du 15 mars
le premier ministre promet au moins 20
millions de personnes vaccinées d'ici la
mi mai outre rhin un plan de
déconfinement progressif adopté mais la
plupart des restrictions être prolongée
au moins jusqu'au 28 mars et dans le
sillage de la france l'allemagne elle
aussi autorise le vaccin astrazeneca
pour les plus de 65 ans en espagne la
crise économique
effet collatéral de la pandémie le pays
dépasse les 4 millions de demandeurs
d'emploi pour la première fois en cinq
ans
dans ce contexte tendu par la crise
sanitaire une perspective qui inquiète
les milieux économiques le retour de
l'inflation pour l'instant mesurer la
hausse des prix semble s'installer à la
faveur de la flambée des cours des
matières premières notamment
alors cette inflation naissante est elle
une menace pour notre pouvoir d'achat
non nous connaître un emballement
comparable à celui des années 70
ce sera l'objet de l'élite aux échos de
jacques saint-pierre
[Musique]
la traditionnelle conférence de presse
tout à l'heure de jean castex et
d'olivier véran l'accent a été mis sur
l'accélération de la vaccination et les
thèses tout en incitant toujours à
redoubler de vigilance pour plus de
précisions nous retrouvons en direct
mona hamou dès lors en direct de
l'elysée un bon soir rona vous avez donc
suivi cette conférence de presse du
gouvernement quelques annonces ont été
faites mais rien de fondamentalement
nouveau et plusieurs annonces du 1er mai
jeudi des vents et comme je l'avais dit
rien de très nouveau
en tout cas justin points déjà sur les
contaminations le vario en lua
représentent 60% des cas de
contamination dans le pays et vous
l'avez dit roy moore département ont
rejoint la liste des vingt départements
placés sous surveillance et s'est
confirmé pour le département du pas de
calais il va être confinés les week-ends
à partir de cette semaine et selon le
premier ministre jean castex et bien il
faut tout faire pour éviter le
confinement et c'est le vaccin qui va
nous aider à sortir de cette crise
sanitaire écoutez le c'est bien d'abord
et avant tout le déploiement le plus
rapide et le plus ciblé possible de la
campagne vaccinale qui nous permettra de
sortir de ce tunnel et mona d'après
olivier vers ans et jean castex la
campagne de vaccination va donc
s'accélérer
nous sommes entrés dans une course
contre la montre se sont elles les mots
du premier ministre alors pour le moment
juste pour vous donner un petit peu en
ordre d'idée 3,2 millions de personnes
ont été vaccinées en france 80% et des
résidents et des pad ont reçu une dose
de vaccin et 60% d'entre eux ont reçu
une seconde dose de vaccin vous n'avez
vu le gouvernement veut accélérer la
cadence il veut aller vite a commandé
plus de vaccins il se fixait fixé
plusieurs objectifs jean castex l'a
précisé
et d'ici et le 15 avril et 10 millions
de personnes devraient être vaccinées
d'ici la mi-mai 20 millions de personnes
devraient être vaccinés et dc lité est
des départs dont 30 millions de
personnes devraient être vaccinés comme
annoncé il y a quelques jours la flamme
vaccination sera également possible dans
les pharmacies le but est de multiplier
le profil des vaccinateurs dès le 15
mars ce sera possible écoutez olivier
rend à ce propos ensuite je vais en vie
a insisté sur la vaccination en ville
par les médecins généralistes dans un
premier temps et donc bientôt par les
pharmaciens cette vaccination en ville
elle prend son essor
c'est un pilier de notre stratégie pour
apporter le vaccin au plus près de nos
concitoyens les pharmaciens pourront
vacciner en officine
et c'est une bonne nouvelle à compter de
la mi mars et le décret sortira demain
qui leur permettra de le faire émana
olivier ferrand qui s'est adressé aux
soignants qui seraient réticents à se
faire vacciner
exactement vous avez dû prendre compte
de toutes ces dernières polémiques qu'il
ya eu des soignants qui étaient
réticents qu'il ne voulait pas se faire
vacciner et bien pas d'application pour
le moment à se faire vacciner mais le
ministre de la santé a été clair pour
protéger les autres ils doivent sauter
le pas et se faire vacciner écoutez le
dès demain j'écrirai une lettre à
l'ensemble des soignants de notre pays
qu'ils soient en ville qu'il soit à
l'hôpital qui soit en établissement
médico social pour les inciter très
fortement à se faire vacciner mais
également évidemment pour les remercier
pour leur mobilisation sans faille
depuis plus d'un an dans la lutte contre
cette épidémie
pour rappel le premier ministre l'a
précisé le confinement n'est pas
impossible
il va falloir donc travailler tous
ensemble pad annonce devrait ouvertures
de restaurants de lieux culturels de
musée de cinéma
le retour à la vie presque normale à la
mi avril semble un petit peu ambitieux
néanmoins olivier vers on a précisé
qu'il pourrait y avoir des ouvertures et
des allègements de restrictions et d'ici
quelques mois merci madame ou dès lors
en direct de l'elysée et alors qu'en
france la vaccination on l'aura compris
on peine à s'accélérer de manière
significative en tout cas plus 2,2
millions de russes se sont déjà fait
administrer les deux doses du vaccin
spoutnik v une déclaration avait dit
mi-août il alors que l'agencé européenne
des médicaments annonce aujourd'hui
seulement avoir commencé l'examen du
vexin russe une étape cruciale avant son
déploiement possible dans l'union
européenne qui connaît des retards de
livraisons de doses dans la foulée est
bon ce qu'on se dit déjà prêt en
fournira 50 millions d'européens dès le
mois de juin une proposition qui séduit
d'ores et déjà la slovaquie et la
république tchèque ces pays ont décidé
de s'affranchir de l'europe en se
fournissant avec le sérum russe sans
attendre les autorisations officielles
la france doit-elle faire de même ne
devrait-on pas reprendre notre
souveraineté quand il s'agit de santé
publique
c'est l'objet de notre face à face ce
soir
et pour en parler nous sommes avec m
[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
philippe froguel généticien chercheur
professeur à l'impérial collège de
londres et à l'université lille 2
bonsoir fini prog et merci d'être avec
nous à vos côtés jean nains à cappelle
député européen est reine
bonsoir à vous aussi alors là jean
saint-onge viens de le dire du
médicament européen qui a commencé
aujourd'hui l'examen du vexin russe
poutine fait étape cruciale a on le
disait en vue de son développement dans
l'union européenne qui en a bien besoin
on rappelle que le vaccin russe a été
déjà utilisée en russie dès l'été
dernier l'étude du land 7 qui confirme
de bons résultats elle elle date de plus
d'un mois un peu plus d'un mois et 2
jours précisément pourquoi seulement
aujourd'hui jean lain à cappelle vos
piètres dans le coeur du réacteur
puisque vous êtes député européen mais
écoutez j'avais moi même formulé en tant
que député européen
une question il ya plusieurs semaines en
demandant pourquoi nous ne faisions la
france les nations aux européennes et
l'union européenne pourquoi après ceux
tel retard ne remet tait pas ne prenent
est elle pas des dispositions pour
justement pouvoir commander combler des
failles et commandé notamment le vaccin
rue ce qu'elle faisait allusion et je
n'ai d'ailleurs jamais eu de réponses à
ces questions que j'ai formulée mais il
est temps en effet que l'union
européenne serait parce que nous avons
eu lieu le fiasco des masques en début
d'année le fiasco des tests en cours
d'année et puis nous avons maintenant
quand même le fiasco des vaccins puisque
je vais parler de la france mais nous
sommes trente septième ce matin d'après
les chiffres 37e rang mondial du nombre
de personnes vaccinées
donc c'est bien avant absolument notre
faible tout à fait incohérent
inacceptable pour la septième puissance
mondiale et l'ensemble de l'union
européenne est extrêmement faible
l'ensemble de l'union européenne
donc nous avons des pays comme la grande
bretagne qui ont vacciné
j'ai les chiffres devant moi plus de 20
millions de personnes quand la france a
vacciné 1 million 700 mille personnes
sur les doses donc on est très en retard
et ce scandale est pas normal il ya une
double faute où il ya je dirais un
double problème il y aller
européenne qui a très mal négocié qui
s'est entouré de personnes qui ne
savaient pas négocié qui a voulu prendre
comme pied d'entrée le prix mais je
crois quand on est en guerre c'est pas
le prix qu'il faut qu'on comprenne c'est
les quantités c'est la rapidité
il faut qu'on soit les meilleurs et ils
n'ont pas su le faire
ils ont été ils ont manqué de
transparence dans les négociations ils
n'ont pas impliquer les nations dans les
négociations et puis très sincèrement
ils n'ont pas su négocier s'entourer
d'experts j'entendais le président
d'astra l'un des vaccins l'autre jour
qui disait eh bien écoutez moi j'ai vu
les contrats il n'y a pas de contrat au
sein de nioro peine c'était des
intentions d'achat en revanche il le
comparer aux contrats des britanniques
il disait le poteau la bernique c'était
au moins claires et des conditions
livraisons élevées des quantités fixe et
délices des des livraisons est l un des
pénalités de retard
vous savez quand on est quand on est en
guerre quand on est bon on doit être
efficace et qu'on va défendre son peuple
et ses peuples ses quais l'union
européenne via l'aurait dû s'entourer
des meilleurs elle n'a pas su le faire
j'espère que elle corrigera le retard
est bien sûr le vaccin russe est une
opportunité pour le faire mais que de
temps que le temps que le temps pour
enfin le faire la hongrie la slovaquie
ont décidé de le faire l'allemagne
d'ailleurs sans le dire a décidé elle
aussi de commander auprès d'autres
laboratoires des vaccins pour combler
cette défaillance européenne la france
est toujours en retard
hainard dans la dernière or on va voir
justement certains pays qui sont
affranchis un certain d'ailleurs ont
déjà reçu le spoutnik vais regarder
cette carte on distingue entre ceux qui
ont déjà passé commande slovaquie
hongrie et république tchèque la
slovaquie qui a été d'ailleurs fourni
cette semaine on pourparlers l'autriche
1 vous l'avez dit j'en ai à la capelle
et puis qui est d'accord pour en
commander quand tu auras les
autorisations l'allemagne s'est déjà
déclaré philippe froguel clairement et
seront devrait s'affranchir selon vous
des règles de l'union européenne
pour aller plus vite au nom de la santé
publique surtout poussé l'union
européenne à être plus actives aller
plus vite
bien entendu mais pas qu'ils aillent
plus vite a aussi débloqué des sous pour
des programmes aura dépassé les vaccins
actuels parce que
il ya des risques aujourd'hui que ces
vaccins ne soit pas efficace j'ai bien
noté que le danemark et l'autriche
faisait une alliance avec israël pour
faire là pour faire ce genre de choses
c'est heureux au niveau européen
si l'europe de la santé existait qu il
faudrait il faudrait faire tout cela
aujourd'hui le choix est très compliqué
c'est vrai qu'on a beaucoup de retard
je pense que la responsabilité n'est pas
que dans la l'europe en tant que tel il
ya eu la présidence allemande et à
l'année dernière il ya eu un jeu avec la
france avec l'italie qui ont voulu se
passer de la com et européenne pour
négocier directement avec des
laboratoires pharmaceutiques
il lancé à leur manière en ne croyant
pas trop aux vaccins et rennes je pense
que c'est comme d'habitude c'est
toujours beaucoup trop facile de s'en
prendre à bruxelles alors qu'il ya une
responsabilité des états je répète de la
présidence allemande de la france et
d'autres qui ont voulu jouer à la fois
leur jeu à dicter ensuite alors les
règles qui étaient mauvaises
à la commission européenne et la
commission européenne
on sait qu'elle est très bureaucratique
on sait qu'elle est très lente et
qu'elle n'est pas fait pour les grandes
crises et c'est bien c'est un des vrais
problèmes et il faudrait que de la
commission européenne et permettre
d'agir vite en cas de pandémie ce qui
est pour l'instant n'existe pas mais
faut quand même rappeler que l'europe de
la santé il n'existe pas c'est pas avoir
été vraiment une prérogative européenne
c'est peut-être quelque chose qu'il
faudra qu'il faudra changer donc nous
répondre à votre question je ne sais pas
s'il faut commander en dehors de
l'europe je sais même pas d'ailleurs ce
qui est permis ou pas permis la seule
chose que moi je dis en tant que médecin
c'est qu'il faut tout faire pour qu'on
ait assez de vaccins pour tous c'est
qu'en france il y en a pas assez
et quelles que soient les
responsabilités d'ailleurs même temps tu
en as assez on n'arrive pas à les
distribuer à quand même près de 75% des
doses de vaccins ce troisième cas qui
n'ont pas été distribuées et c'est
peut-être ça le principal problème en
france
revenir à sous et nick si le vaccin est
scooté que sans marcher aussi bien qu'il
en a l'air je ne vois pas pourquoi on se
prive à des bassins puisque de toute
façon en france je ne vois pas
exactement comment le président de la
république pourra tenir ses promesses
puisque à la seconde
on n'a pas de possibilité de vacciner un
million de personnes
avant avant l'été et donc il faudra bien
faire vrai tenir de la kz1 d'ailleurs je
voudrais vous faire goûter un coup de
coeur celui du docteur laurent alexandre
qui trouve qu'en matière de vaccination
justement les 27 n'ont pas été bon mais
alors pas bon du tout écouter l'europe
s'est ridiculisée l'angleterre a bien
mieux réussi que l'union européenne est
aujourd'hui de ralentir de prendre un
mois de retard sur l'enregistrement du
vaccin johnson and johnson qui al
avantage de n'avoir qu'une prise c'est
grotesque
c'est dramatique donc l'union européenne
c'est une faillite complète sur ce
programme vaccinal le royaume uni donc
il réussit mieux que nous selon laurent
alexandre 600 mille doses par jour on
répète ce chiffre c'est un petit peu la
revanche j'en alain capelle des états
souverains fini pour elle nous le disait
ça serait bien que les états puissent
aussi décider seul sans sa franchissent
enfin c'est pas exactement vos mots mais
en tout cas voilà en donnant peut-être
moins de pouvoirs à la commission
européenne qui sont responsables de
leurs propres décisions mais enfin voilà
le royaume uni prouve que lui peut
prendre d'essai ses décisions de manière
souple c'est cette revanche de l'état
nation aux gens là la capelle mais vous
l'avez parfaitement dit et d'ailleurs
l'exemple de la grande bretagne et est
symptomatique c'est l'illustration
exactement de ce que happy souverain est
capable de faire plus que la grande
bretagne n'aurait jamais vacciné autant
de personnes si elles étaient encore
intégré bien sûr à l'union européenne
elle a vacciné aujourd'hui 30% de la
population avec une première dose 30% de
la population
plus de 20 millions de personnes quand
nous sommes nous les français à 4,5 pour
cent autant vous dire que il ya même pas
de comparaison possible
il ya même pas d'excusé possible nous
sommes aujourd'hui dans un piège qui est
l'union européenne qui vous lisiez
professeur qui en effet normalement n'a
pas dans ses prérogatives
la santé mais pourtant pourtant après le
fiasco des masques
après l'abandon de l'italie notamment
qui criait sos aubade mars dix ans on
n'a pas de matelas de protection
aidez nous et personne ne la soutenait
l'europe avait promis de devenir une
grande robe de la santé et il en avait
fait un point d'honneur à démontrer
justement que l'union européenne pouvait
nous protéger en fin dé protéger les
peuples européens
eh bien elle s'est encore trompée elle a
encore failli et on n'y arrivera pas en
effet tant qu'on est constitué de cette
manière là avec une europe fédérale où
tout est contrôlé par bruxelles et où
les peuples donc peuvent pas avoir une
souveraineté la souveraineté elle est
indispensable sur des missions
importantes
et quand on déclare que nous sommes en
guerre il faut bien sûr redonner des
pouvoirs aux français l'union européenne
a interdit aux nations européennes de
négocier parallèlement auprès de
laboratoires avec lesquels elle négocier
donc d'une part elle les a pas intégrées
elles avaient intégré dans la
négociation d'autre part alors interdit
de négocier alors je dis dans son
association qui complètement dingue
vous savez c'est la même situation
permettez moi ce parallèle même
situation que sur la fermeture des
frontières
le 24 janvier dernier nous demandions
par la voie du rassemblement national de
le président de marine le pen la
régulation des frontières
tout le monde nous rionnais en dix ans
le virus n'a pas de passeport vous êtes
ridicule vous êtes irresponsables et
vous êtes extrémistes eh bien écoutez il
a fallu un an un an pour que l'union
européenne comprenne que réguler les
frontières ça permet quand même de
stopper et de freiner le virus et
l'allemagne d'ailleurs vient de fermer
ses frontières de la france
elle vient de faire baisser avec la
tchéquie elles viennent service avec
l'autriche donc en fait tout le monde le
comprend au bout d'un an ou des raisons
idéologiques et dogmatique
on est piégé on va se poser on va en
profiter
l'éminent ce et expertise
évidemment du professeur froguel la
fermeture des frontières justement
précoce ça aurait empêché une certaine
circulation du virus sont c'était un
combat perdu d'avancé pour vous et des
pays qui ont réussi à faire du zéro co
vide en bloquant mieux les frontières
que nous par exemple
ce qui est clair aujourd'hui c'est quand
on arrive à roissy et contrôler son
minimum et à dunkerque la semaine
dernière il y avait plusieurs personnes
qui avaient le col l'aco vide avec un
variant sud africain et qui disait
matinée du côté des comores et de
l'autre d'afrique du sud justement et
qui était très étonnée d'avoir eu aucun
contrôle
essayez là aujourd'hui d'aller en corée
du sud comme des de france pas chez un
fils de la mezam i qu'il l'a fait c'est
pas simplement avec votre test pcr d'il
ya deux jours aux enfers en arrivant on
vous met en quarantaine
on le teste 3 fois antigénique pdc ar et
c est donc ce n'est que quand vraiment v
sûr que vous n'êtes pas porter comme
voulais centrer c'est bien entendu pas
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui en france
et c est inquiétant est que vu la
circulation du virus un peu partout dans
le monde
il va y avoir des nouveaux variants qui
vont apparaître peut-être en france mais
peut-être dans un autre pays au brésil
où il ya une très forte circulation
d'autres et ici on n'arrive pas à
bloquer ça on va se retrouver avec
encore une floraison de l'homme du
variant froguel de votre exemple et est
particulièrement intéressant parce que
vous êtes à la fois travailleurs en
angleterre puisque vous travaillez
l'impérial collège de londres et à
l'université de lille on vous laisse
passer facilement d'un pays à l'autre
parce que une fois que le royaume uni se
sera débarrassé de son virus grâce à sa
vaccination il s'agira peut-être pas
d'aller leur voile alors
et apporté depuis la france alors que
nous on sera un petit peu en retard
c'est une vraie question ça moi je
crains que l'on soit parmi les derniers
la france a vacciné très largement notre
population qui va y avoir des sortes de
passeports vaccinaux qui vont se met un
peu partout ce qui va rentrer la
population française suspecte et on va
avoir des difficultés à mon avis pendant
l'été à seulement aller en vacances
ailleurs ou de travailler parce que on
sera très très suspect et d'autres
mettront en place des contrôles des
frontières que nous on n'a pas été
capable de faire et qu'apparemment on a
des preuves de logistique un petit peu
partout aujourd'hui en france et c'est
ça que je n'arrive pas là où j'ai
vraiment un désaccord est ce que tu avec
moi c'est que j'ai des amis qui ont
participé à la négociation des vaccins
pendant l'été pour grandement français
et je veux un peu l'impression qu'une
dès que des erreurs qui avait été fait
était plus de notre niveau
ensuite au niveau européen mais ensuite
la bureaucratie européenne a repris la
main et aggraver tout ça mais il ya eu
des fautes 13 apporte pas entendre la
faute principale était de ne pas faire
confiance à pfizer et aux vaccins modern
art puisque on pensait que cette île qui
marcherait jamais il est serait
dangereux qu'il fallait mieux attendre
d'autres vaccins comme le sanofi et oui
comme vous le savez n'arrivera jamais il
ya eu çà au sein de l'union européenne
jean lacasse la capelle la france qui a
voulu miser sur son vaccin
malheureusement qui s'est avérée voilà
pas très fructueux juste avant de vous
répondre bien sûr je réponds aux
professeurs qui a été d'une grande
honnêteté intellectuelle parce qu en
effet j'ai été vous savez ces derniers
mois en russie au kazakhstan au liban à
lille la réunion dans différents
endroits je suis revenu en france je
n'ai jamais été contrôlé et je suis
député européen comme vous le disiez
donc je fais deux allers-retours par
semaine entre bruxelles et paris je
viens de rentrer de bruxelles dans un
train qui provenaient de d'amsterdam
je n'ai pas été contrée le gars du nord
donc ça n'est pas acceptable très
sincèrement ça n'est pas acceptable
aujourd'hui que dans tous les pays du
monde y ait des frontières qu'ils soient
rigoureuses stricte et qu'en france il
n'y en ait pas et quand vous êtes
contrôlés s'il n'avait pas votre test
on vous met une amende de 50 euros vous
ne refuse même pas l'intégration sur le
territoire on vous met vu une amende de
130 euros
ça n'est pas sérieux ça n'est pas
raisonnable ensuite pour revenir à votre
question
bien sûr on a failli mais je vais vous
reprendre l'exemple de valve neva vous
savez cette magnifique start-up cette
magnifique petite boîte dans l'ouest de
la france qui produit des vaccins et
bien dont on n'a pas su profiter et
c'est les britanniques qui ont
finalement acheté l'ensemble du stock
parce qu'ils étaient les premiers tout
simplement à négocier et j'ai beaucoup
d'autres raisons comme cela donc ça et
quand on est la septième puissance
mondiale et quand on n'a pas un site de
production quand on n'a pas un propres
vaccins avec l'institut pasteur avec
sanofi dont on nous faisait état
promesses on me dira vous inquiétez pas
nous aurons notre vaccin on s'aperçoit
que on a abandonné la recherche on a
totalement désinvesti dans ce domaine là
la délocalisation de là dessus et aussi
pendant des années et sanofi en est
aussi responsable très sincèrement comme
le gouvernement français mais nous
sommes mauvais c'est malheureusement le
cas de le dire alors je souhaite que on
se rattrape pas ce que je souhaite pour
protéger notre peuple
je souhaite que tout le monde puisse se
vacciner tous ceux qui le souhaitent
puissent être le plus rapidement
possible écoutez moi mes parents 85 ans
il habite paris je n'arrive pas à les
faire vacciner
ils ont 85 ans on téléphone y a rien à
faire tout est pris tout est pris on
leur propose et argenteuil d'aller à
argenteuil pour fin mars avec une
deuxième dose 75 jours après c'est à
dire hors limite
je ne comprends même pas le système je
ne comprends même pas les règles a subi
tant est forte pardonnez moi je vous
coupe mais d'ici l'été un sas et jean
castex jeudi nous aurons suffisamment de
doses pour avoir proposer la vaccination
à 30 millions de personnes soit les deux
tiers de la population de plus de 18 ans
donc c'est quand même ambitieux le mot
de la fin pour le professeur froguel
vous y croyez vous dirai juste voilà ma
conclusion ce sera parole parole nous
verrons c'est la fin de la foire qu'on
compte les bouses vadam mi match
philippe froguel le mot de la fin vous y
croyez à ses pronostics optimistes et à
ses promesses voeu du premier ministre
pour que on arrive à faire ça il
faudrait que vraiment une vraie
stratégie vaccinale qui n'a pas et
notamment à préparer le monde d'après
c'est là où elle n'est pas par exemple
est intéressant ce que les anglais me
l'utilisent
pour une nouvelle génération de vaccins
adaptés à tous les variantes qui
pourraient apparaître
la deuxième c on a une méthodologie et
la logistique
et tant qu'on n'aura pas de la
logistique je ne vois pas comment on
arriverait à administrer 30 millions de
vaccins alors que on n'arrive pas en a
extrait quelques centaines de milliers
j'attends de voir une logistique qui
fonctionne en france et là effectivement
je commencerai à y croire à la seconde
le passé et nous dit quand même que le
futur et pas obligatoirement aussi
radieux que messieurs casse technologies
merci en tout cas on terminera sur ses
paroles
philippe froguel jenlain la capec merci
d'avoir été avec nous pour ce second
coup face à face ce soir rassemblement
des acteurs de la culture aujourd'hui un
peu partout en france depuis un an et
les premières restrictions sanitaires
l'activité est au ralenti voire à
l'arrêt un secteur d'activité qui tente
aujourd'hui d'alerter le gouvernement et
demande des décisions fermes et
immédiates luis carballo avec maxime
rosières les professionnels du monde de
la culture était dans la rue aujourd'hui
le but pousser un nouveau cri de
ras-le-bol pour demander la réouverture
des lieux culturels
un an après les premières restrictions
imposées par le gouvernement
a lyon ils étaient plusieurs dizaines à
se rassembler devant la célèbre halle
tony garnier
les manifestants qui regrettent
notamment le mutisme de la ministre de
tutelle roselyne bachelot ministre on
l'entend pas
et nous on nous a dit de jouer elle a
fait près de la figuration au
gouvernement donc ça c'est pas juste
pourquoi elle fait de la figure et nous
on peut rien faire on voit là nous on
aimerait que les théâtres ouf comme les
supermarchés parce qu'il ya des
meilleures choses dans les cas qui dans
les supermarchés les mesures sanitaires
me tue voilà bah oui je suis dans le
monde artistique du violoniste et c'est
ma raison de vivre
et si on enlève ça j'ai pu vraiment
envie de vivre en fait voilà le tout
simplement toi même cri de désespoir à
marseille
plusieurs acteurs du monde de la culture
se sont réunis cet après midi à 14
heures devant l'hôtel de ville de la
cité phocéenne même image à toulouse où
près de 500 personnes se sont réunies
devant la préfecture mise en place pour
aider les intermittents du secteur
l'année blanche dispositif exceptionnel
d'indemnisation doit prendre fin au mois
d'août prochain
certains demandent qu'elle soit
prolongée bien sûr nous avons eu l année
blanche qui permet de
qui a pris en charge les intermittents
jusqu'au mois d'août
mais dans la mesure où la période
d'impossibilité d'impossibilité de
travail et s'est prolongée donc on
appelle à une prono une prolongation de
l'année blanche
[Musique]
ça peut être par secteur dans la mesure
où effectivement peut-être que le cinéma
continue à travailler en production mais
en ce qui concerne le spectacle vivant
on est vraiment dans une situation on
court à la catastrophe
ce soir à paris des manifestants sont
entrés dans le théâtre de l'odéon avec
l'intention d'y passer la nuit
ils demandent un rendez vous d'urgence
avec jean castex et roselyne bachelot
même si plusieurs concerts tests sont
organisées aucune date de réouverture
des lieux de culture n'a été annoncé
pour l'instant reste avec nous dans
quelques instants nous parlerons de
l'inflation naissant en france est ce
une menace pour notre pouvoir d'achat
jacques sapir tentera de répondre à
cette question et puis direction le robe
ou l'allemagne adopte un plan de
déconfinement progressif et autorise
également le vaccin astrazeneca pour les
plus de 65 ans
la crise sanitaire aurait creusé encore
un peu plus les inégalités entre les
plus riches et les plus pauvres il y à
un million de pauvres en plus on est
passé de 9 à 10 millions de pauvres
on a 20 % des français qui ne mangent
pas à leur faim nous ne sommes pas en
france on a l'impression d'être en train
de passer dans un pays du tiers-monde
le problème il est bien en amont il est
depuis que les banques centrales
intrigues de l'argent et quand l
intrigue de l'argent en fait ça ne va
pas dans l'économie réelle
ça va juste sur les marchés financiers
la cause de la paupérisation de la
france de la tiers-mondisation sur la
cnops s'engage si la destruction de
l'industrie française réindustrialiser
c'est pas juste en claquant des doigts
vous faites revenir les sociétés d'abord
il faut changer complètement fou c'est à
dire tout ce qui les a fait partir il ya
une débauche d'argent qu'on met sur le
sur la table sans se préoccuper de
savoir qui au final va payer au final
c'est toujours les mêmes les dindons de
la farce c'est toujours les mêmes vers
qui on va se tourner pour aller payer la
note
vous êtes né dans la musique vous êtes
né dans une famille d'artistes le désir
révélée brutalement par la prise de
conscience du concert symphonique qui
m'a donné envie d'être chef d'orchestre
ça a balayé tout le reste c'est un acte
d'amour la musique pour vous oui mais
l'art en général vous savez ça permet de
mieux se connaître ça permet de mieux
partager c'est la part d'humanité
incontournable et indispensable à
l'évolution de tout être humain quand
j'entendais pata pata pata pata pata
pata pata pata pata pata papa papa pata
pata
vous avez envie de faire ça va aller il
faut que leur qu'istres groove la
musique c'est la traduction la plus
poétique de la vie si vous mettez pas la
vie des villes à mon sens bête
il faut sortir les notes de leurs
univers carcéral
mais il faut jouer ce qui a entre les
notes et avant tout c'est le rythme et
la pulsation et ça c'est fondamental
pour entraîner et l' enthousiasme des
musiciens et celui du public
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ni 20h30 soyez les bienvenus en direct
sur rt france si vous nous rejoignez
dans le contexte déjà tendu de la crise
sanitaire
une perspective qui inquiète les milieux
économiques le retour de l'inflation
pour l'instant mesurer la hausse des
prix semble s'installer à la faveur de
la flambée des cours de matières
premières et alors que les banques
centrales continuent de faire tourner
leur planche à billets alors dans quelle
mesure cette inflation naissante est
elle une menace pour notre pouvoir
d'achat
allons-nous connaître un emballement
comparable à celui des années 70 c'est
l'objet de l'édito échos ce soir bonsoir
et que sa pire
bonsoir ces feignasses aujac sommes nous
vraiment à la veille d'une forte poussée
d'inflation comme certains en tout cas
le craignent c'est tout à fait normal
que les gens craignent l'inflation
parce que s'il y avait une inflation
maintenant alors que les revenus sont
absolument gelé ça pourrait avoir des
conséquences tout à fait grave
mais si on en croit les chiffres de
l'insee il n'y a pas de réel redémarrage
de l'inflation est en tous les cas il
n'y a pas de problème à court terme même
si il y a à l'évidence un problème lié
lui à la question des matières premières
et donc ça veut dire que sur la question
de l'inflation
et bien tout n'est pas aussi simple
qu'il y paraît alors chacun commençons
par le commencement si j'ose dire que
disent les chiffres de l'inflation
bon si on prend les chiffres de l'insee
on voit tout de suite que le taux
d'inflation en france n'a jamais été
aussi bas on était au début des années
1990 autour de 2 3%
on est tombé sauf un petit pic
d'inflation en 2018 on est tombé en
dessous de 1%
donc on voit bien là qu'il n'y a pas de
problème immédiat en tous les cas y
envoyer qui a pas de tendance à la
remontée de l'inflation même si et ça
c'est un point qu'il faut qu'ils vous
bien regarder il y a depuis quelques
mois une petite tendance à la remontée
de l'inflation
alors pourquoi cette crainte diffuse
alors il faut savoir que quand on parle
de l'inflation et quand l'insee parle de
l'inflation à l'analyse diverses choses
il ya évidemment l'indicé des prix à la
consommation c'est ce qu'on appelle
glaume globalement l'inflation et puis
il ya un autre indice qu'on appelle
l'inflation sous jacente
ce sont les prix des matières premières
alors on le voit aussi sur ce graphique
il y à une baisse globale de l' indice
des prix à la consommation et de
l'inflation sous jacente
sauf que depuis la fin du quatrième
trimestre et avec les premiers mois de
l'année et bien l'inflation sous-jacente
qui est cette courbe rouge qu'on voit à
côté des courbes bleus et des courbes
jaune
et bien cette courbe rouge elle est en
train de remonter et cette inflation
sous jacente
il faut le savoir c'est essentiellement
les matières premières et le pétrole
alors justement jacques à quoi est due
cette hausse des matières premières en
particulier comme vous le dites des
cours du pétrole
alors pour ce qui concerne le pétrole on
est dans une situation qui est quand
même très intéressante
rappelez vous il ya un an au mois de
mars 2020 on avait fait une émission où
on parlait des prix négatifs du pétrole
le pétrole était au plus bas
il a remonté c'est en partie normale
mais il a remonté très vite il a été en
moyenne autour de 54 dollars au mois de
janvier soit il sera probablement 60
dollars au mois de février et il ya des
analystes qui disent qu'ils pourraient
atteindre jusqu'à 75 dollars d'ici la
fin de l'année
qu'est ce qui se passe mais ils se
cassent deux choses d'une part on a des
pays qui ont redémarré 1
la chine a redémarré les pays qui sont
autour de la chine la corée taïwan le
vietnam etc ont redémarré donc qui dit
redémarrage économique dit
besoin d'énergie besoin de pétrole d'un
autre côté les pays producteurs eux ont
beaucoup baissé leur production à cause
de la crise qu'on a connus avant même
les effets de la crise sanitaire
cette crise du pétrole que l'on a connu
au mois de mars de l'année dernière et
ils ont maintenu d'une certaine manière
les contraintes sur la production alors
ajoutons à cela évidemment la vague de
froid qui a touché les états unis le
texas et de dakota qui sont deux zones
importantes de production et donc on a
aujourd'hui un déséquilibre important
entre eux la demande pour le pétrole et
la production et c'est pour cela que les
prix sont en train d'augmenter
mais jacques ce phénomène est ce qu'il
est limité au marché du pétrole
non justement et c'est quelque chose
d'assez important on voit que l'ensemble
des prix des matières premières est en
train d'augmenter alors on voit là aussi
sur ce graphique que savaient chuté avec
la crise sanitaire mais que là ça
remonte et ça remonte de manière
particulièrement important qu'est ce que
ça veut dire
eh bien ça veut dire qu'il y à des
pénuries alors on sait qu'il ya des
pénuries sur les matières premières
mais ce qui est encore plus intéressant
il faut savoir qu'il y a désormais des
pénuries sur des biens manufacturés les
microprocesseurs et ça ça tout de suite
des conséquences extrêmement importante
pour la production des voitures pour la
production d automobiles
c'est ce qui va d'ailleurs faire monter
d'une certaine manière le prix des
automobiles
mais il n'ya pas que ça il y a les
matières plastiques les produits en
plastique qui sert par exemple pour
l'emballage des médicaments pour
l'emballage devax justement donc
globalement c'est tout ce qu'il y a en
amont de la production industrielle qui
est en train aujourd'hui de connaître
des hausses de prix importants et comme
les français consomment et c'est naturel
beaucoup de produits manufacturés est
bien et il va y avoir nécessairement un
impact de cette hausse des prix est la
question qu'on peut se poser pourquoi de
tel désordre
alors là encore il faut revenir un petit
peu au contexte général on a des pays
comme je les dis qu'ils ont redémarré
c'est effectivement les piles à 10 et
des pétitions au tour de la chine
à côté de ça on à l'europe qui
globalement n'a pas encore redémarré la
france
un kyste anne et on le voit là sur l'
indice de la production industrielle
nous sommes encore au début de l'année
2000 21 nettement en dessous du niveau
que l'on avait atteint à la fin de
l'année 2019 bien mais même en europe
on a des pays où l'activité est en train
de redémarrer plus vite qu'en france et
plus vite que dans le reste de l'europe
c'est par exemple le cas de l'italie et
c'est le cas de l'espagne et dans ces
deux pays
les producteurs industriels commencent à
se plaindre justement de cette pénurie
de matières premières du fait que ben
ils sont obligés d'augmenter leurs prix
pour attirer la production vers eux
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que globalement on est dans une
situation où avec le redémarrage de
l'activité économique
alors que la production globale n'a pas
encore surmonté les effets de la crise
eh bien on va avoir des tensions
relativement importante et ces tensions
importantes vont provoquer une hausse
des prix alors jane dans quelle mesure
c'était notre question de départ est ce
que c'est une menace pour notre pouvoir
d'achat
quelles conséquences concrètes pour les
consommateurs que nous sommes
alors oui ça va avoir des conséquences
bien sûr ça ne va pas être des
conséquences dramatiques
vous aviez parlé en introduction de la
situation des années soixante dix
on ne sera jamais dans cette situation
si vous voulez on va pas retrouver une
inflation à deux chiffres ce qu'on avait
connu au début même des des années 80
par contre il n'est pas du tout
impossible que l'on est en 2021
un taux d'inflation de l'ordre de 2%
ce qui aurait des conséquences parce que
je le rappelle les revenus sont restés
relativement gelé et puis plus
particulièrement il y à ce problème par
exemple du prix des matières premières
du prix des carburants
rappelons-nous le mouvement des gels et
jaune il a été provoqué par une hausse
du prix des carburants
donc il va falloir surveiller de manière
extrêmement précise
cette situation et nous sommes
aujourd'hui dans une situation où avec
la baisse de la productivité qui est le
résultat tout simplement des mesures
sanitaires qui sont prises dans nombre
d'entreprises
eh bien on va avoir je dirais des
goulets d'étranglement au niveau des
approvisionnements et c'est goulets
d'étranglement pour et pendant cette
année provoqué une hausse des prix en
particulier sur les produits
manufacturés et bien merci jacques pour
cet éclairage qui donne comme toujours à
réfléchir merci à vous et à la semaine
prochaine
en europe on le disait la situation
sanitaire est différente d'un pays à
l'autre face à la progression du variant
britanniques notamment à bologne italie
a choisi de fermer ces établissements
scolaires l'allemagne elle souhaite
donner
un peu d'espoir à ses habitants sans
complètement relâché la pression
les présidents de médiers ski fis niveau
de restriction situation économique
pression hospitalière trois paramètres
décisifs qui varient d'un pays à l'autre
en europe à bologne en italie ce de plus
en plus de jeunes sont touchés par des
formes graves du code vide avec des
chiffres en hausse la ville pourrait
rapidement entrer en zone rouge
un contexte sanitaire qui inquiète les
professionnels de santé
ce qui a changé dans cette population de
patients c'est qu'il ya beaucoup plus de
patients relativement jeunes atteints de
maladies graves
une courbe des contaminations bien
différente de celle de l'allemagne qui
reste sur des chiffres en recul par
rapport aux précédentes semaines
la chancelière a même ouvert la porte 1
déconfinement progressive dans pays
à sept mois des élections législatives
angué la merkel doit faire face aux
critiques qui proviennent parfois de son
propre gouvernement
la dirigeante a fini par envisager la
réouverture des établissements
considérés non essentiel sauf si le taux
d'incidence du virus reste stable ou
diminuer pendant 14 jours nous pourrons
passer à l'étape suivante au plus tôt le
22 mars
elle concernera la restauration au plein
air sur réservation préalable avec un
taux d'incidence de plus de 50 et sans
réservation avec un dos en dessous de la
barre des 50
elle concernera également les théâtres
les salles de concerts et opéras et les
cinémas dont l'entrée sera permise grâce
à détester rapide rab s'écriront octobre
elle tenait caisse en espagne c'est la
courbe du chômage qui inquiète et une
insécurité alimentaire grandissante dans
le pays le nombre de chômeurs a dépassé
les 4 millions février un chiffre qui
n'avait plus été atteint depuis 2013
d'après le ministère du travail
la faillite de nombreuses entreprises
entraîne une hausse de la pauvreté
la distribution de nourriture provoque
des files d'attentes interminables
les autorités ne peuvent que constater
les dégâts collatéraux de la pandémie
temps des paroles évidemment ce ne sont
évidemment pas de bons chiffres
comme vous avez pu le constater ils sont
principalement le résultat de
l'intensité de cette troisième vague
dans un état tel fait le relais à baïdoa
gaulle est face à une situation
différente d'un pays à l'autre
l'europe tente tout de même de
s'organiser pour limiter les dégâts ce
lundi la commission européenne a annoncé
sa volonté de mettre en place un
passeport qu'ovide pour faciliter les
déplacements à travers le continent
mais pour évoquer la situation de
l'allemagne à nous sommes avec peter
oliver correspondant d'arte et à berlin
c'est notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
ce soir très bon soir
peter oliver merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france 9 heures d'âpres
négociations comme souvent d'ailleurs
entre la chancelière et les dirigeants
des 16 états régions du pays hier la
chancelière qui a dû céder face au
mécontentement croissant de la
population allemande
de big and switch and son intercession
entre la chancelière et le dirigeant des
16 états régionaux ont cours depuis le 5
novembre et aimable ces négociations
toujours été très tendue ce que nous
avons constaté hier c'est une variation
la plus difficile et la plus âpre mais
il ya toujours étonnant et du donné
qu'il ya eu des échanges de documents
entre eux son conseil le matériel et
érigeant des états allemands elle
souhaitait que le déconfinement se fasse
le 28 mars elle a obtenu cela elle
voulait également les restrictions ne
soient assouplies savent que lorsque on
atteignait un taux d'incidence de 35 cas
par 100 mille habitants elle a dû
reculer sur ce point et ils sont tombés
d'accord sur 50 pour cent mille âmes et
nous reviendrons dessus bientôt iphone
c'est donc la patience effectivement
c'est depuis les avec le confinement en
allemagne les dirigeants des régions
affectées ont résisté au centre le
volonté de la chancelière et et cela a
été tout au long de la crise les
gouvernements régionaux tous qu'une
réouverture de locaux but est bien plus
rapide que le souhaiterait le
gouvernement fédéral à berlin
et cela continue nous car la grande peur
du gouvernement fédéral
la grande peur des scientifiques et des
épidémiologistes en allemagne son ca les
variants de la cofidis ne pourrait avoir
un effet sur la population
alors c'est vrai qu'il faut le rappeler
contrairement au président macron ils
sont vraiment à l'opposé aux gays
macron j'allais dire en gala merkel et
emmanuel macron il y en a un qui veut
vraiment par confiner ça sera le dernier
recours et il faut rappeler que la
chancelière elle a toujours été sur
cette stratégie le confinement à tout
prix pour maintenir la santé de la
nation
bien sûr ne souhaiterait pas être plus
mal à combien sur sa prépa à partir à la
retraite
voilà je crois que cette audi en deux
phrases effectivement peter en tout cas
la stratégie du gouvernement allemand
s'appuie sur le déploiement de tests
antigénique ce n'était pas déjà le cas
en allemagne ces tests antigénique jan
steen aujourd'hui notamment par la voix
du ministère de la santé
c'est qu'ils vont déployer de nouveaux
tests de bias plus efficace plus
performants qui soit disponible
gratuitement très souvent dans de
nombreux endroits et cela concilier avec
la vaccination c'est le fond de la
stratégie du gouvernement allemand qui
permettra de maîtriser la provident ce
nom que l'on à jcs qu'il cherche à
atteindre ce nombre de 54% du vital pour
mettre en place ce plan graduelle se
composera de cinq étapes vers la
première étape père c'était le 1er mars
les écoles ont pu réouvrir est la
seconde étape au chaud manceau jean
marcel et l'italie les first pour mieux
ouvrir dans les régions on est en
dessous de 2 54% des musées des eaux
pourrait également ouvrir mais n'allons
pas trop loin pour le moment ce jeudi
salle 2 ha remplissent ces critères de
54 cents habitants c'est la latina et le
schleswig holstein
donc tous et des états pourrait rouvrir
leur commerce
mais dans d'autres états tels que la
thuringe
on dépasse les 100 cas pour ce militant
chen serait le 22 mars si le nombre de
54 alors il y aurait davantage de
réouverture au lp si on atteint le 5
avril
encore d'autres commerces et d'autres
institutions pour ouvrir mais il y aura
une conférence avant cela entre la
chancelière et les dirigeants des états
le 24 mars et ils réviseront reverront
la façon dont le conflit d'été
confinement se fait et évalueront si on
peut continuer pour renforcer des
mesures et autres sujets évidemment
comme partout à un peter lieber la
vaccination et la lenteur de la campagne
de vaccination
tout comme en france d'ailleurs qui
exaspère de plus en plus les allemands
ne s'est pas bien passé le gouvernement
allemand ne peut pas retourner
positivement ils n'ont pas bien gérer le
déploiement vaccinale est très bon prix
ont bien réussi
les allemands ont reçu leur dose de
vaccination exaqtworld comme au céret un
revirement total concernant le vaccin
astrazeneca le gouvernement disait qu'il
n'est pas assez d'information et pouvoir
façonner des personnes de plus de 65 ans
avec le vaccin est aujourd'hui ils
disent que toi cette formation et qu'on
doit espaces et les deux donc c'est le
contrat doit ce que tu pars avant les
allemands comme les britanniques mais
plusieurs mois de retard et la campagne
de sensibilisation a été très étrange
concernant le vaccin astrazeneca
je vise ici je travaille si je suis
britannique enfin fait longtemps graves
au vaccin et entendre ma famille me
parler du vaccin astrazeneca mes parents
l'ont reçue et ensuite comparer cela à
la politique allemande qui est de ne pas
le donner aux personnes de plus de 65
ans et c'est très bizarre et le
gouvernement allemand s'étant limiers
maintenant sur la position de man
française et beaucoup d'allemands sont
très mécontentes du programme de
vaccination le gouvernement ne peut plus
changer les serrures du passé ils
peuvent que changer l'avenir changer de
position concernant le astra zeneca et
ils ont deux doses en stock en allemagne
qui peuvent commencer à distribuer à
ceux qui en ont le plus besoin
non mais ça changera peut être la donne
effectivement et la manne qui s'ouvre
aussi aux vaccins foot nick v on le
rappelle puisqu'un gala marquez s'est
dit prêt à en commander le footing mais
qui étudiait à partir d'aujourd'hui par
l' agence du médicament européenne merci
à vous peter oliver d'avoir été avec
nous correspondons berthet à berlin pour
vu de l'extérieur en espagne est présent
le pays a terminé le mois de février
avec 4 millions de chômeurs selon les
chiffres publiés par le ministère du
travail
premier effet
notoire de la pandémie sur l'emploi les
précisions de leslie issing là notre
correspondante à barcelone et oui c'est
du jamais vu depuis cinq ans le pays
subit de plein fouet la troisième vague
de coronavirus et les mesures en vigueur
en février ce sont plus de 45000
personnes qui se sont inscrites au
chômage
et parmi elles plus des deux tiers
travailler dans le secteur des services
alors il faut rappeler contre les
restrictions mobilité et les fermetures
imposée par le gouvernement espagnol
pour freiner la propagation de
coronavirus les bars les restaurants
mais aussi l'hôtellerie et le tourisme
sont fortement touchées dans le pays
en ce début d'année l'agriculture est
également impactée tandis que
l'industrie reste stable alors parmi les
quatre millions de chômeurs ils ne
prennent pas en compte les 900 milles
personnes qui sont encore au chômage
partiel en espagne à l'automne le
premier ministre pedro sanchez avait
déjà annoncé la création de 800 mille
postes de travail en trois ans pourtant
le pib en 2020 s'est effondré de 11%
c'est l'un des pires résultats de la
zone euro alors désormais tous les
regards sont portés vers le mois d'avril
où les secteurs espèrent une reprise de
l'activité et une en relâchement des
mesures pour une reprise du tourisme
mais en italie plusieurs ong dont
médecins sans frontières en dans le
viseur de la justice elles sont
soupçonnées de collusion avec des
trafiquants de migrants et de cette
coordonnée avec des passeurs pour fixer
des points de rendez-vous en mer les
détails en images
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous reviendrons sur le malaise qui
touche le monde agricole manifestation
aujourd'hui à paris au moment où le
salon de l'agriculture devaient se tenir
les agriculteurs dénoncent le manque de
prix rémunérateurs
le coc vie des gammes en conférence de
presse tout à l'heure de jean castex le
compliment est confirmé le week-end pour
le pas de calais a pas de hausse
exponentielle de l'épidémie à ce stade
[Musique]
vous êtes né dans la musique vous êtes
né dans une famille d'artistes désir
révélée brutalement par la prise de
conscience du concert symphonique qui
m'a donné envie d'être chef d'orchestre
ça a balayé tout le reste c'est un acte
d'amour la musique pour vous oui mais
l'art en général vous savez ça permet de
mieux se connaître ça permet de mieux
partager c'est la part d'humanité
incontournable et indispensable à
l'évolution de tout être humain quand
vous entendez pata pata pata pata pata
pata pata pata pata pata papa papa pata
pata
vous avez envie de faire ça va aller il
faut que leur qu'istres groove la
musique c'est la traduction la plus
poétique de la vie si vous mettez pas la
vie des évidemment on s'embête il faut
sortir les notes de leurs univers
carcéral
mais il faut jouer ce qui a entre les
notes et avant tout c'est le rythme et
la pulsation et ça c'est fondamental
pour entraîner et l' enthousiasme des
musiciens et celui du public
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
c'était positif n'a jamais été obligé de
dire la vérité
les ide et courageuse des mots qui
comptent la haine en soi vient des murs
aujourd'hui on a une gauche extrêmement
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview avec les
accords d'abraham le président américain
reconnaît la souveraineté du maroc sur
le sahara fuyant la france comme
l'europe a été absente de l'ensemble de
cette négociation qui impactent
directement deux pays dans lesquels nous
avons des liens privilégiés depuis fort
longtemps la république algérienne et le
royaume du maroc des algériens
évidemment mécontents considère la
décision américaine comme une ingérence
dans un problème interne
le maroc a toujours été considérée comme
une menace politique économique et
militaire
face à cette situation conflictuelle
entre les deux pays la france aurait
ainsi l'occasion de participer à la
construction d'un maghreb pacifiées
[Musique]
certains donnent confiance est rompu
entre le politique et les experts même
les citoyens on est une société qui est
tellement percuté et on ne peut pas
considérer une démocratie vit
véritablement l'amplitude de ses
possibles et non politique de ses
valeurs quand elle est à ce point
confiné est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment on repart à zéro par rapport à
l'année dernière
la société ne survivra pas à une
succession de confinement une société
c'est pas le confinement
c'est la liberté c'est la créativité
c'est le sentiment d'exister
d'appartenir
comment on va réorganiser le monde y la
pandémie c'est vivre
[Musique]
la crise sanitaire pourrait creuser
encore un peu plus les inégalités entre
les plus riches et les plus pauvres il
ya un million de pauvres en plus on est
passé de 9 à 10 millions de pauvres
on a 20 % des français qui ne mangent
pas à leur faim nous ne sommes pas en
france on a l'impression d'être en train
de passer dans un pays du tiers-monde
le problème il est bien en amont il est
depuis que les banques centrales
intrigues de l'argent et quand l intérim
de l'argent en fait ça ne va pas dans
l'économie réelle
ça va juste sur les marchés financiers
la cause de la paupérisation de la
france de la tiers-mondisation sur la
cnops s'engage si la destruction de
l'industrie française réindustrialiser
c'est pas juste en claquant des doigts
vous faites revenir les sociétés d'abord
il faut changer complètement fou c'est à
dire tout ce qui les a fait partir il ya
une débauche d'argent qu'on met sur le
sur la table sans se préoccuper de
savoir qui au final va payer au final
c'est toujours les mêmes les dindons de
la farce c'est toujours les mêmes vers
qui on va se tourner pour aller payer la
note
[Musique]
il ya à peu près un enfant sur deux en
france qui est soit victime soit hauteur
de cyber violence sur internet un
contenu haineux de quelqu'un qui dit à
une fillette de 8 ans on va te suicider
ça ça doit être retirée immédiatement il
n'ya aucun débat à avoir sur son retrait
là parce que ça ça fait des suicides la
loi le condamne déjà c'est déjà interdit
de faire ça bien sûr mais c'est juste
que les gaffes à ne l'appliquent pas la
justice est lente et c'est très
problématique qui va prendre ce rôle de
régulateur la loi peut aider l'éducation
peut aider selon les différentes
catégories d'attaquants et d'attaquer
une erreur de la loi via ça a été de
tout mettre dans le même panier sous le
sous le nom est dans l'hymne quel rôle
pour les réseaux sociaux on a vu et big
for donc les gaffes à s'organiser pour
annuler quelqu'un sur internet c'est
quelqu'un c'était donald trump quand il
s'agit d'un bannissement si général pour
moi ce n'est pas aux gaffes à et aux
réseaux sociaux hanul à des entreprises
privées de prendre cette décision mais
ça doit être à la justice de prendre
cette décision
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
demain
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'émission tout de
suite voici les titres de l'actualité de
ce jeudi 4 mars le malaise du monde
agricole manifestation à paris
aujourd'hui au moment où le salon de
l'agriculture devaient se tenir
événement très important pour la
profession est annulé en raison de la
crise sanitaire les agriculteurs
entendent dénoncer le manque de prix
rémunérateurs mais aussi alerter sur les
disparitions d'exploitations et le
suicide d leur confinement confirmer le
week-end pour le pas de calais trois
départements rejoint la liste de ceux
vigilance renforcée aux alpes n et aube
est la campagne vaccinale et son
accélération au coeur des annonces de
jean castex et d'olivier véran la
vaccination aux cibles en pharmacie à
compter de la semaine du 15 mars le
premier ministre pour mais au moins 20
millions de personnes vaccinées d'ici la
fin mai
[Musique]
outre-atlantique le capitole sur le qui
vive la sécurité renforcée la police
américaine a fait état d'un projet
d'assaut du siège du congrès prévue
aujourd'hui
alors que le bâtiment avait déjà été
pris pour cible par des manifestations
pro trump le 6 janvier
depuis cette date des membres de la
garde nationale patrouillent toujours
dans l'enceinte du capitole protégée par
des barrières et des fils barbelés les
ivoiriens appelés aux urnes samedi pour
les élections législatives pour
renouveler leur 255 députés pour la
première fois depuis dix ans presque
tous les partis d'opposition sont
représentés une campagne dans une
atmosphère apaisée alors que le 31
octobre dernier en marge de l'élection
présidentielle des violences avaient
écarté et cahiers etc a éclaté pardon et
fait 87 morts et près de 500 blessés
[Musique]
manifestation d'agriculteurs aujourd'hui
donc à paris objectifs du rassemblement
alerter sur le malaise de la profession
une action organisée au moment où le
salon de l'agriculture devait se tenir
un événement très important pour la
profession est annulé en raison de la
crise liée aux kovy 19 des mannequins
ont symboliquement été pendue pour
dénoncer l'absence de considération de
l'état
l origine de cette protestation le
syndicat a coordination rurale pour son
président les agriculteurs sont une
variable d'ajustement
le vrai visage de l'agriculture c'est
les fermes qui ferme c'est pour ça qu'on
a fait ce manifeste c'est qu'elle se
sente de dépôt de bilan par an donc des
agriculteurs qui ont de gros soucis
financiers
et c'est aussi deux agriculteurs par
jour qui continuera à se suicider on a
passé aussi une partie du moins de 2 des
négociations avec la grande distribution
et on nous dit toujours qu'on ne peut
pas payer parce que le consommateur
aujourd'hui n'a pas trop d'argent et
cherche des prix bas or on reste
toujours nous la variable d'ajustement
et on est aujourd'hui la seule catégorie
qui travaillent en dessous des coûts de
production
nous sommes un secteur stratégique
emmanuel macron l'avait rappelé après la
santé c'est l'agriculture mais moi je
rappelle ses seuls les agriculteurs
il ya eu un documentaire où on était un
million six amis l'après guerre et
aujourd'hui on est quatre amis et on va
finir à 300 mines et si aujourd'hui on
n'organise pas entre l'agriculteur et le
consommateur par de la
contractualisation et des prix
rémunérateurs et vais demain on aura pas
de l'agriculture partout ne pas faire
rien qu'une vision financière avec les
milliards magique que l'on voit partout
il faut se dire qu'aujourd'hui vont
mettre l'argent sur l'agriculture parce
que nous sommes un secteur stratégique
et je rappelle que nous sommes les
premiers écologistes de france et pour
en parler nous sommes avec véronique le
floch vice président de la coordination
rurale bonsoir héros nikkei
merci d'être avec nous à la
manifestation aujourd'hui on pouvait
lire sur les banderoles l'agriculture
française subit un énorme plan social
organisé dans le plus grand silence
parlez nous de ce plan social ce sont
quoi les vents trop souvent à perte
bonsoir à tous
disons pourquoi ce message les fermes
qui ferment ce top aux fermes qui
ferment et pourquoi s'adresser au
parisien pourquoi d une campagne
d'affichage dans les métros parce que ce
que nous subissons les parisiens le
subissent aussi quelque part et ils ne
savent pas que les fermes ferme et il
faut qu'on leur explique qu'en des
fermes ferment ce sont des exploitants
qui ne produisent plus et c'est une
forme de délocalisation qui s'est par
exemple si je prends l'exemple de des
asperges
il y a 20 ans on produisait en france
dix mille hectares là même la même
surface qu'en allemagne
en allemagne on produit aujourd'hui
vingt-deux mille hectares en france on
ne produit plus que 4000 hectares c'est
cette forme de délocalisation qui est le
résultat d'une politique de prix ne
couvrent en plus nos coûts de production
expliquez-nous véronique le flop parce
que c'est intéressant ce que vous nous
dites justement roudil voilà dans les
villes et parisien où les autres hein
c'est très important parce que c'est une
bonne alimentation
les produits locaux qui
de ne pas très loin de chez nous
expliquez nous justement cela la france
à son agriculture qui a été classée pour
la troisième année consécutive comme
étant la plus durable au monde et cette
agriculture elle peut pas se faire sans
agriculteur est aujourd'hui en fait le
ratio qui fait que pour une exploitation
derrière chaque exploitation il y à cet
emploi ce sont sept emplois rémunérés
alors même que les agriculteurs ne le
sont plus et l'origine de ce malaise
c'est d'abord la politique et je dirais
même la politique européenne puisque en
92 avec cette politique de soutien à
l'agriculture pour nous faire produire à
des prix mondiaux fait que on a lancé
tout un commerce et que nos industriels
se sont justement inscrit dans une
logique de commerce avant une logique de
souveraineté autant avec les pays tiers
on a pu commercer en commerce c'est plus
de 180 milliards exportés avec une
balance positive de 60 milliards donc ça
c'est l'europe et avec les pays tiers et
la france c'est tout aussi bénéfique
par contre cette politique européenne
avec des échanges intra européen qui
pèse pour près de 330 milliards fait que
des français mangent des produits
d'ailleurs d'europe et nos bons produits
français ceux issus de l'agriculture la
plus durable se trouve ailleurs mais là
on est perdant c'est bien parce que nous
nous avons une agriculture qui répondent
à des normes supérieures et nous avons
aussi un coût horaire qui est bien
supérieur at on aujourd'hui clairement
quand on vous écoute les moyens de ce
protectionnisme
comment expliquer justement que là que
la france subisse
réglementation plus stricte alors qu'on
est au sein de l'ocs qui nous permet
manifestement pas de protéger les
agriculteurs français
c'est un peu contradictoire est plus
tout à fait je dirais plutôt pourquoi
les politiques nous laisse justement
entre dans dans ce marché mondialisé
mais qui finalement est très pénalisant
déjà au sein de l' europe 1 si je vous
donne l'exemple de la viande les
quantités de viande exporté en frais par
la france 1 près de 200 mille tonnes
ce sont les mêmes quantités qui sont
importés
franchement tout ça devrait être
davantage encadré pour que nos
industriels et là je vise aussi bien les
industriels privés que les industriels
coopératif privilégie la matière
première française
il n'y a pas à cette pression des
différents gouvernements parce que voilà
ça fait plusieurs années qu'on parle de
ce débat c'est un débat qui ne semble
pas se terminer ça veut dire que tous
les gouvernements successifs de droite
comme de gauche ne font pas assez pour
l'agriculture française
en fait ce qu'ils ne font pas c'est un
calcul pour mettre en parallèle chacune
des productions pour là on exporte et je
pense par exemple aux céréales comme
vous le montrer juste à l'instant pour
laquelle la balance commerciale est
bénéficiaire de 5 milliards d'euros
mais face à ces 5 milliards on a quand
même donné près de trois milliards
d'euros aux producteurs français aux
céréaliers et et finalement c'est comme
si on exportait ses aides
donc la france fait de mauvais calculs
et c'est pas faute de la répéter et
l'acr justement la coordination rurale
veut informer les consommateurs pour
justement que ce soit les produits
français qu'ils soient transformés dans
nos industries françaises pour d'abord
la commercialiser au niveau français est
ce que le consommateur a un rôle à jouer
dans cette affaire comment petit vous
aider le consommateur finalement là le
consommateur peut d'abord dénoncé au
même titre que nous le faisons ensuite
son acte d'achat
il ne peut acheter que ce que ce que lui
est ce qui lui est proposé
donc quand on sait que la france exporte
beaucoup de volaille et on en importe
beaucoup aussi
mais d'ailleurs d'europe et beaucoup de
des copains
si bien que le consommateur a une chance
sur deux d'acheter un poulet d'un port à
chaque fois qu ils en achètent et c'est
ça qui doit être davantage encadré pour
justement produire de les produits qu'on
ne veut plus importés on garde d'abord
le produit pour le consommateur et c'est
aux consommateurs mais je pense qu'il le
dit assez sauf qu'il est impuissant face
à ce qu'il a dans les rayons oui un
autre
un autre motif de manifestations
aujourd'hui qui ont rejoint évidemment
tout ce qu'on dit puisque son nez la
terrible conséquence 372 suicide
d'exploitants agricoles recensés en 2015
ce sont les chiffres les plus récents
que vous possédez cet immense
ça paraît incroyable ça fait plus d'un
suicide par jour chez des agriculteurs
alors le malaise il a été pris en charge
la par un député olivier damaisin qui en
a fait un rapport qui aboutit à une
conclusion des quatre aires alors je
voulais citerai pas mais en tout cas ils
demandent du réconfort
il oublie juste une chose c'est la
responsabilité dans son rapport bien
qu'ils nous aient aussi auditionné il ne
condamne pas les responsables des
suicides chez les agriculteurs
or nous agriculteurs nous sommes
à la merci de tous les industriels des
banquiers et nous sommes un secteur qui
qu'on ne peut pas cesser ou faire cesser
comme un menuisier maçon
on a une structure dans laquelle on ne
peut faire que de l'agriculture si bien
qu'on a des coopératives
on a des banques on a beaucoup de
partenaires qui continuent à nous
soutenir abusivement en nous prêtant
beaucoup plus d'argent qu'on a besoin
qu'on a investi les coopératives qui
continue à nous avancer de la
marchandise des aliments justement pour
récupérer le produit à ce que ce soit le
lait ou autre chose et ce soutien abusif
la devrait être condamnée pour ne pas
nous laisser nous endetter et et finir
justement plutôt que des liquides et
finir au bout d'une corde
merci véronique laflamme vice présidente
de la coordination rurale d'avoir été
avec nous et conférence de presse du
gouvernement ce jeudi donc le premier
ministre jean castex annoncé de
nouvelles mesures pour contrer
l'épidémie parmi celles ci le
confinement le week-end dans le
département du pas de calais le
placement de trois nouveaux départements
en surveillance renforcée ou encore
l'accélération de la vaccination point
complet avec quentin mauclair
l'information avait chuté mercredi soir
le pas de calais est bien le seul des
vingt départements surveillance
renforcée qui sera concerné par un
confinement lors des prochains week-ends
l'incident ci est en effet en
progression très rapide 23 % au cours
des sept derniers jours et dépasse je le
disais dorénavant le seuil des 4 100
pour cent mille habitants soit presque
deux fois la moyenne nationale
le niveau de saturation des services de
réanimation se situe au plus haut de
tous les départements français
pas de mise sous cloche partiel donc
pour l'ile-de-france où les
bouches-du-rhône où les élus locaux
s'étaient opposés à cette mesure
dans le même temps trois nouveaux
départements rejoignent la liste des
territoires placé en surveillance
renforcée
len l'aube ainsi que les hautes-alpes
autre mesure annoncée pour ans
l'épidémie dans les départements en
surveillance renforcée le port du masque
deviendra obligatoire en extérieur dans
l'ensemble des zones urbaines les
centres commerciaux non alimentaires de
plus de 10 mille mètres carrés ne feront
quant à eux fermés leurs portes
de plus jean castex a encouragé
préfecture et municipalités à prendre
des mesures au sujet des manifestations
et des espaces extérieurs à forte
fréquentation
les préfets seront également invités en
concertation bien sûr avec les maires
concernés à interdire ou à réglementer
l'accès de certains sites très
fréquentés pendant les week-ends où l'on
observe des regroupements de masse trop
souvent sans masque ni distanciation par
cohérence
les préfets pourront être amené à
interdire les manifestations organisées
dans l'espace public notamment pendant
les week-ends
lorsqu'elles présenteront un risque
sanitaire avéré au regard de leurs
conditions d'organisation
l'ensemble de ces mesures entreront en
vigueur dès ce vendredi sur le plan
vaccinal le gouvernement a prévu
d'accélérer le rythme des injections
dans les prochains mois l'exécutif se
fixe l'objectif d'au moins 20 millions
de personnes vaccinées à la mi mai grâce
notamment à l'arrivée en france du
vaccin astrazeneca
de plus il sera possible de se faire
vacciner dans les pharmacies dès la
semaine du 15 mars
la haute autorité de santé a donné son
approbation et le décret autorisant
cette nouvelle étape majeure dans notre
stratégie de vaccination sortira demain
la vaccination se passera comme pour la
grippe vous n'aurez pas besoin d'une
prescription médicale et vous pourrez
vous rendre directement à nos officiers
malgré l'accélération prévu des
vaccinations le gouvernement prévient
que les prochaines semaines seront un
minima tout aussi compliquée que les
précédentes
jean castex a exclu tout assouplissement
des mesures même territorialisée sans
amélioration globale de la situation et
pour parler de ces nouvelles annonces
jean castex on s'amuse avec philippe
laurent maire udi de sow secrétaire
général de l'association des maires de
france bonsoir fini torrent merci d'être
avec nous alors la nouvelle évidemment
qui vous concerne assauts également
l'ile-de-france pas confiner le week-end
c'est une confirmation ce soir c est un
vrai soulagement du côté de sault
également un soulagement peut-être pas
parce que nous avions écrit
effectivement discuter de tout cela avec
le préfet bon et je pense que la mesure
qui a été prise et plutôt plutôt une
bonne mesure mais je ne voudrais pas que
ceci ne lance un message trop positif
auprès de notre population de nos
populations
parce qu'il faut continuer naturellement
comme l'a dit le point une liste
d'ailleurs est respectée les gestes
barrière le port du masque les jauges
dans les commerces ça c'est très
important aussi et et faire en sorte que
les grands rassemblements n'existe pas
alors qu'il ya encore beaucoup de
pédagogie beaucoup d'accompagnement à
faire pour nos concitoyens faut pas
s'imaginer que parce qu'il n'ya pas de
confinement on peut faire comme avant
c'est vraiment un message important ça
je trouve qu'il faut que nous fassions
attention mais évidemment c'est une vie
un peu moins difficiles qui s'annoncent
pour nos concitoyens avec notamment le
maintien de l'ouverture des parcs et
jardins
le maintien de l'ouverture des écoles
c'est aussi quelque chose qui est très
important auquel nous tenons beaucoup
alors le pas de calais c'est pas la même
chose à un certain élus d'ailleurs ne
comprennent pas ce deux poids deux
mesures vous êtes également on l'a dit
un responsable au sein de l'association
des maires de france
vous comprenez un petit peu la colère de
nos amis du nord sur genton ce qu'a dit
notamment mon collègue de daniel
fasquelle que je connais bien
alors l'association des maires de france
à a toujours souhaité que soit soit
territorialisée les mesures donc nous
nous comprenons aussi et nous sommes
d'accord pour dire qu' il peut y avoir
ponctuellement pendant quelques semaines
des mesures différentes d'un territoire
à l'autre d'ailleurs c'est le cas à nice
aussi il n'ya pas de calais yao
s'initient à dunkerque et là comme vous
l'avez vu les élus étaient plutôt
d'accord avec ça donc bon je pense que
bon tout ceci est une affaire de
réglages mais je pense que nous pensons
que les mesures tarifaires réalisées
c'est plutôt bien parce que on voit bien
que tu avais veut pas dire que demain
par exemple pas de calais pourrait être
d confiné complètement alors que l'île
de france où une partie des 2 france
pourrait être beaucoup plus confiné tout
dépend de la façon dont les choses vont
évoluer
mais c'est une crise que nous n'avons
jamais connu que aucun gouvernement n'a
connu et donc il est assez normal je
trouvais assez naturel que le
gouvernement donc géré ça un petit peu
donc un peu à vue mais pas comment faire
autrement pour faire en sorte de ne pas
doubler la crise sanitaire par une crise
économique c'est déjà un peu le cas et
surtout par une crise morale parce que
c'est là où est le sujet voilà donc je
pense que les mesures qui sont prises
sont plutôt adaptée à la situation
alors le moral un parlons-en parce que
le couvre feu de 18h c'est pas terrible
non plus soyons honnêtes vous appelez
d'ailleurs eu à le retarder d'une heure
ainsi les informations sont bonnes pour
quelles raisons oui tout à fait nous
avons alors j'étais allé un des premiers
à le dire mais enfin une les maires des
hauts-de-seine notamment ont demandé au
président examiné de fermenter l'idée de
pouvoir décaler le couvre-feu en effet à
19 heures la raison en est simple c'est
que nous avons constaté dans nos villes
dans les commerces et supermarchés qui
avait quand même beaucoup de monde entre
17 heures et 18 heures parce que
évidemment les gens puisque en fait on
continue quand même à travailler
les enfants continuent à l'école donc
forcément il y a le rythme de la vie
fait qu' un certain nombre de démarches
de course etc ne peuvent être faites que
à ce moment là et donc c'est trop court
cette période est trop court et nous
pensons que la vraie lutte en fait
contre l'avis la diffusion du virus
c'est d'éviter les rassemblements
d'éviter les concentrations de personnes
ça c'est le sujet numéro un est bien
pour éviter ça il faut étaler sur une
heure et demie à deux heures la fin de
journée pour que les gens puissent faire
leurs courses plus tranquillement
philippe laurent malheureusement vous
n'avez pas été entendu ce soir et c'est
vrai qu'on a tous constaté voilà dans la
queue au supermarché à 18h30 assez pour
se dépêcher
le vendredi soir c'est c'est vrai que
c'est quoi ces c'est un gouvernement
hors sol qui ne sais pas voilà ce que
c'est on simplement peut-être d'aller
faire les courses et de vivre comme tout
à chacun d'aller chercher ses enfants à
l'école c'est de cela qu'il s'agit
non je n'irai pas jusque là mais je
dirais que nous allons continuer à faire
entendre notre voix auprès du
gouvernement pour lui de lui suggéré
d'examiner avec attention une plus
grande attention encore notre
proposition qui vous paraît être une
proposition de bon sens et qui ne remet
pas en question les principes même des
règles qu'il a lui même fixée et dont
nous partageons donc la grande de la
grande majorité
donc on va continuer à dire que pendant
tout cas pour ce qui concerne la région
parisienne où on vit enfin on est un peu
en décalage peut-être par rapport à des
agglomérations de province est en route
plus tard et c'est bon on va continuer à
lui dire au gouvernement que il nous
paraît que 19 heures c'est mieux que le
18 heures voilà alors un autre sujet du
rapport et on espère peut-être un autre
sujet qui met parfois en porte à faux
les maires de france c'est la
vaccination il ya beaucoup de personnes
âgées même
on entendait un témoignage tout à
l'heure 85 ans qui a du mal à avoir un
rendez vous l'objectif de jean castex 20
millions de personnes vaccinées d'ici la
mi mai vous ne vous y croyez à cet
objectif qui semble à ce jour un petit
peu il réalisable en tout cas oui c'est
vrai que si on prend le rythme actuel
est qu'on le prolonge naturellement un
territoire qu'il faut vraiment accéléré
alors sur ce sujet il ya deux choses qui
sont importantes
évidemment c'est d'abord la faune la
fourniture des doses là ne maîtrisons
pas nous élus locaux ne maîtrisons pas
des choses ça c'est le gouvernement qui
est pétri zh a priori il y à une
accélération de la livraison des doses
il ya notamment le modern a qui arrivent
enfin bref donc il ya une et puis
d'autres vaccins peut être d'ici au 18
avril ou mai donc par conséquent bas
c'est de débarrasser le gouvernement qui
sait ce qu'il fait qui c'est lui qui a
négocié des achats le deuxième sujet c
est ce que nous sommes capables nous
élus locaux avec les médecins de ville
avec les pharmaciens
est ce qu'on est capable d'organiser un
système de vacciner deux vaccinations de
base qui permettent de vacciner autant
de personnes
nous nous disons oui nous disons oui
nous avons d'ores et déjà organisé dans
certaines communes des centres de
vaccination qui fonctionne il ne
fonctionne pas à plaindre parce qu'il
n'ya pas assez de doses mais pour fb xi
mais beaucoup plus et j'ai cru
comprendre que le gouvernement allait
ouvrir allait proposer d'ouvrir d'autres
centres de vaccination je suis donc
moi-même concernés puisque nous avons
proposé avec mes deux villes voisines de
bourg-la-reine et d'anthony d'ouvrir un
centre mutualisé
le gouvernement a donné son accord il a
signé l'arrêté aujourd'hui le centre
court déjà le 15 mars
donc on aura une capacité en tout cas à
traiter les vaccins beaucoup plus
importante ça on sait le faire nous les
élus locaux
nous prenons cet engagement 1,2 de
mettre en place les conditions
matérielles de mobiliser les
professionnels de santé
dodo territoire pour que ça fonctionne
maintenant le vrai sujet encore une fois
ce sont les douilles
si le gouvernement fournit les doses on
y arrivera merci philippe laurent merlet
de sceaux d'avoir été avec mon direct
sur rt france la france au rang des
mauvais élèves justement de la
vaccination rien
parler dans l'union européenne ou dans
le monde tous les pays ne progresse pas
au même rythme et l'hexagone accuse un
sérieux train de retard elle est devancé
par des pays comme la pologne la
roumanie à l'intérieur de l'union ou
encore à l'extérieur par eux israël ou
les émirats les détails avec estelle
farges au 27 février la france a
administré 4,5 millions de doses de
vaccin selon les statistiques du site à
world in data elle se situe juste
derrière le champion de l'union
européenne l'allemagne avec 5,9 millions
de doses injectées mais en fin de compte
cela représente seulement un peu plus de
6% de la population
un pourcentage qui fait dégringoler
l'hexagone dans le classement des
leaders de la vaccination
la france est loin très loin même de la
première marche du podium trusté par
israël
93 5 % des israéliens ont reçu au moins
une première dose de vaccin anti
qu'ovide 19 au 28 février
elle est aussi derrière des pays comme
les etats-unis avec 22 5%
le maroc avec 9 75% ou encore les
émirats arabes unis avec 60,81 7% au
sein de l'union européenne la france
aussi accusent un retard
le pays se retrouve derrière la pologne
la roumanie ou encore l'espagne emmanuel
macron s'était pourtant engagé à ce que
l'ensemble de la population adulte du
moins ce qu'ils souhaitent puissent être
vaccinées d'ici à la fin août 2021
malgré ce retard en france le
coordinateur de la stratégie vaccinale
contre le coc vide 19
alain fischer s'est montré plutôt
optimiste quant à l'évolution de la
vaccination
le problème principal est de s'assurer
que les livraisons arrivent en temps et
en heure le programme potentiel des
livraisons va croissant de façon très
nette en mars et encore plus en avril
mieux qu'en février s'il n'y a pas de
mauvaise surprise dans les livraisons
il y a potentiellement de quoi vacciner
l'ensemble de la population adulte au
cours de l'été sauf qu'au rythme actuel
et en partant du principe que tous les
adultes français désirent recevoir le
vaccin
il faudrait attendre juillet 2
1023 pour que ces 52 millions de
français soit vaccinée c'est en tout cas
ce qu'estime le site qu'ovide tracker
autant dire qu'il va falloir mettre les
bouchées doubles pour tenir la promesse
présidentielle je lai 2023 ça fait loin
effectivement rester avec nous dans
quelques instants nous partirons aux
états unis où la police américaine a
fait état d'un projet dassault du
capitole prévue aujourd'hui alors que le
bâtiment avait déjà été pris pour cible
par des manifestants pro trump le 6
janvier
et puis direction la côte d'ivoire
élections législatives ce samedi les
ivoiriens vont renouveler leur de 155
députés pour la première fois depuis dix
ans presque tous les partis d'opposition
seront représentés
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que notre peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi qui ai des camps dit
elvia pas d'alternative au sort du pays
il est clair que tout le monde attend
saft est ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers uniforme c'est quand même
des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inutile et gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer qu une
sixième république qui ne soit pas un
oubli parlementaire ça se passe en
direct puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté je vous
remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
vous insistez beaucoup sur l'aspect des
dépenses publiques ce que je critique
c'est que on est dans un état
d'addiction de grande dépendance à la
dépense publique je ne veux pas du sang
et des larmes leçons et lamont les actes
et géraud de dépenses trop d'état je
pense en tout cas qu'il ya trop de
bureaucratie c'est à dire un état
inefficace tout ça a été financée
essentiellement par de la dette
le problème est moins la dette en
réalité moi je pense qu'on remboursera
la dette par la croatie donc il faut
essayer de libérer l'économie française
et notamment le travail
notre problème en france c'est un
problème où la dépense publique et est
excessive
mais surtout elle n'est pas productive
les français n'en ont pas pour leur
argent
de ce point de vue emmanuel macron n'a
rien changé par exemple par rapport à
son prédécesseur françois hollande
[Musique]
temps
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes né dans la musique vous êtes
né dans une famille d'artistes désir
révélée brutalement par la prise de
conscience de concerts symphoniques qui
m'a donné envie d'être chef d'orchestre
ça a balayé tout le reste c'est un acte
d'amour la musique pour vous oui mais
l'art en général vous savez ça permet de
mieux se connaître ça permet de mieux
partager c'est la part d'humanité
incontournable et indispensable à
l'évolution de tout être humain quand
vous entendez pata pata pata pata pata
pata pata pata pata pata papa papa patin
patin
vous avez envie de faire ça il faut que
leur qu'istres groove la musique c'est
la traduction la plus poétique de la vie
si vous mettez pas la vie des évidemment
on s'embête il faut sortir les notes de
leurs univers carcéral
mais il faut jouer ce qu'il ya entre les
notes et avant tout c'est le rythme et
la pulsation et ça c'est fondamental
pour entraîner et l' enthousiasme des
musiciens et celui du public
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
21h30 soit il est bienvenu en direct sur
rt france si vous nous rejoignez à
washington la sécurité du capitole
renforcer en cause la menace d'une
attaque de la mouvance qua none ses
membres considèrent que donald trump
aurait dû être investi pour un second
mandat
ce 4 mars et explications de solenn
gaudin patrouille de la garde nationale
routes barrées des centaines de mètres
de barbelés à washington le quartier du
capitole april allures d'une enceinte
militaire
les autorités craignent qu'un assaut des
adeptes de qua none ses membres d'une
mouvance conspirationnistes partisans de
donald trump sont convaincus que
l'ancien président doit revenir au
pouvoir ce 4 mars date de l'investiture
des présidents américains avant 1937
ce mardi la chambre des représentants a
anticipé de vote qui permettant 1 430
parlementaires de ne pas revenir au
congrès avant la semaine prochaine une
décision en d'une extrême nécessité
selon les mots de mark warner sur la
chaîne de télévision cnn ce mercredi
soir ce sénateur démocrate de virginie
encore sous le choc des événements du 6
janvier dernier
des fidèles de qua none et autres
partisans de donald trump avait
violemment envahi le capitole pendant
que le congrès certifié la victoire de
joe biden les images choc avaient fait
le tour du monde
un assaut meurtrier cinq personnes ont
été tuées dont un policier
plus de 270 personnes impliquées sont
actuellement poursuivis selon le fbi
l'attak avait entraîné le second procès
en destitution de donald trump accusé
d'incitation à l'insu révèle également
provoqué un tollé international sur le
manque de préparation et de réaction de
la police du capitole
ce jeudi les forces de l'ordre ont pris
les devants barricadant le haut lieu de
la démocratie américaine menacée par une
partie de ses citoyens et pour en parler
nous sommes nous avec à nicolas conc'air
porte-parole des républicains orsys
france beau soir au caire merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france une
menace que vous preniez au sérieux chez
les républicains et peut-être que vous
craignez alors on peut être constaté que
washington a des airs de ville fortifiée
et ce depuis avant l'investiture en
effet il ya des murs des barricades des
renforts policiers en nombre
on nous fait part de menaces donc qu'ils
sont de sources crédibles seulement
peut-être que c'est un peu
disproportionné effectivement il ya plus
de militaires et de journalistes
présents que deux piétons qui se
baladent actuellement dans les rues de
washington
donc si menaces il ya lieu de prendre
très au sérieux
concernant le fait que c'est peut-être
quelque chose qui va se pérenniser ce
maintien dans la durée c'est ce qui est
à craindre
et on peut redouter que ce soit un peu
un chiffon rouge qu'ils soient utilisés
par les démocrates pour peut-être passé
à couvert d'autres d'autres textes de
loi qui cherchent à passer en sous-main
en ces derniers temps alors c'est vrai
que les images tout de même du 6 janvier
était et est choquant c'est un petit
traumatisme tout de même aux états unis
vos quêtes plutôt partisan de donald
trump ce n'est pas vraiment la meilleure
façon de
faire revenir si donc donald trump ont
ce jour du 6 janvier lui avait appelé à
magnifier de manière patriotes et de
manière pacifique
en exerçant donc le droit fondamental
constitutionnel qu'est le premier
amendement de la constitution sur les
divers débordements n'ont pas été faits
en son nom ils ont été condamnée
fermement par notre organisation des
républiques à nos racines et par donald
trump
je rappelle que ces 75 millions de
personnes qui ont élu donald trump et on
parle de quelques centaines de
manifestants qui se sont emparés de
manière criminelle du capitole donc les
la portée et le mouvement qu'a initié
donald trump est là pour durer c'est un
commencement et il a pu
voilà réaffirmé un petit peu son
autorité est vraiment son influence au
sein du parti avec la convention qui
s'est tenue ces derniers jours orlando
en floride
aujourd'hui c'est une minorité vous
estimez ces manifestants violents a
notamment issus de du mouvement qua none
que représente donald trump chez les
républicains
aujourd'hui mais comme je vous disais
lors de la convention qui s'est tenue la
semaine dernière en floride à orlando
ça a été un vrai à une vraie une vraie
démonstration de force du parti
républicain que donald trump a lui-même
unifiée et derrière lequel nous nous
inscrivons avec les républicains
overseas à savoir voilà un parti unifié
reconstruit fidèle à ses valeurs qui ont
été initiées par donald trump et qui
sauront nous mener vers des victoires à
venir et ce dès les élections de mi
mandat dans deux ans et avec très fortes
ambitions de fortes chances de
l'emporter pour le prochain rendez vous
c'est le cas chez les publics aux
versets mais ma question c'est est ce
que vous êtes en majorité finalement
derrière donald trump pour le parti
républicain aujourd'hui et est plutôt
divisé le parti il est tout à fait
unifié il ya une certaine frange avec
des personnalités qui sont bien
identifiés qui sont un peu les membres
un peu de l'establishment du parti
républicain
davant qui ont cherché un pass rafting
une conscience à peu de frais un peu de
par opportunisme avec qui ont voté en
faveur d'une pichenette donc à rappeler
que donald trump a été blanche
il ne sentait une deuxième fois dans ce
procès d' impeachment et ça ça ne fait
que voilà qu'à soir sa position de force
et l'impulsion qui la suit lancé il y a
qu'à voir ces les urnes qui qui
s'exprime
lorsque les candidats ont été parrainés
donc on dit en dehors c'est par par la
présidente rump ça leur a valu une
manière quasi systématique des élections
de remporter l'élection ou d'être
reconduits à leur poste
donc voilà l'influencent l'aura et la
dynamique initiée par donald trump
elle est là elle est puissante et elle a
un fort courant au sein du parti
républicain
en tout cas il est sorti du silence
donald rome le week-end dernier en
laissant penser
voilà en tout cas laissant la porte
ouverte à une candidature en 2024 vous y
croyez vous à cette candidature on peut
raisonnablement penser que les menaces
en tout cas de joe biden durant tout le
mandat pour barrer la route à donald
trump n'auront pas s'arrêter de sitôt
ça c'est une chose et on l'a vu avec ce
procès dinkic monde qui allait jusqu'à à
vouloir s'en prendre un citoyen lambda
plus en exercice donc vraiment
outrepasser le domaine du loi du droit
pour ce qui était de donald trump
effectivement il nous a manqué et il a
la parole est vraiment il a bien sûr
remobiliser tout ça toutes ses troupes
on pouvait pas s'attendre à ce qu'ils
restent claquemuré dans son domaine de
mara lago en floride il a vraiment à
coeur de jouer un rôle dans la sphère
politique ça soit en parrainant des
candidats en mobilisant le pignon sur
des sujets que sont la liberté
d'expression dans l'espace public dans
les médias dans les réseaux sociaux et
donc c'est tout autant de combat qui va
mener pour pouvoir faire entendre la
voix du peuple américain
comment justement les américains dans
leur ensemble réagissent à tout cela est
que les choses se sont un petit peu
apaisé on sait que c'était une amérique
est extrêmement fracturée au moment de
l'élection est ce qui est un peu
d'apaisement en ce moment mais ça irait
un petit peu à l'encontre du sujet qu'on
présente avec les menaces qui sont
portés sur washington qui combien même
l'est de la ville est calme en état de
siège
je puise assuré qu' il n'y aura pas de
mobilisation violente du moins du camp
républicain il n'y a pas de ya pas de ça
de risque de ce point de vue là c'est
vraiment des images qui ont
considérablement marqué et qui ont été
condamnés de manière unanime par par les
républicains et par donald trump
en ce qui est donc de l'ain apaisement
ou non et on voit surtout qui émarge à
180 degrés qui a été prise par
l'administration by donne alors que ben
john al trump lui s'étaient mobilisés
pour rendre l'amérique et les américains
au centre du dispositif de la lettre joe
biden lui renoue avec des traités
internationaux qui pénalise fortement
les états unis et les travailleurs
américains en coupant des projets de
pipe line et voilà reportant vraiment
fortement atteinte à la puissance
économique qui est des états unis et
notamment le working class merci nicolas
le bilan de la répression en birmanie
s'est alourdi selon les nations unies au
moins cinquante quatre manifestants ont
été tués depuis le début du soulèvement
populaire le 1er février dernier les
précisions avec robin pu hélas malgré la
répression la contestation ne faiblit
pas
plus d'un mois après le coup d'état
militaire des milliers de personnes sont
une nouvelle fois descendus dans les
rues des principales villes du pays ce
jeudi un mouvement de contestation que
la junte semble de plus en plus
déterminé à écraser
d'après l'onu au moins 38 personnes ont
été tuées mercredi par les forces de
sécurité qui ont tiré à balles réelles
sur les manifestants
une journée sanglante que les civils ne
sont pas prêts d'oublier
on ne leur pardonnera pas ce qu'ils ont
fait pas seulement pour cette fille mais
aussi pour les autres qui ont sacrifié
leur vie
on n'oubliera pas ce qu'ils ont fait le
moment venu la multiplication des
violences a provoqué de nouvelles
réactions de la part des dirigeants
occidentaux
emmanuel macron avait clamé l'arrêt
immédiat de la répression
boris johnson en a fait de même et s'est
dit horrifié par la situation
discours similaire aux états unis qui
appelle la chine à user de son influence
auprès des généraux birmans
de son côté pékin se concentre sur la
stabilité politique et sociale du pays
la chine a eu des contacts avec toutes
les parties en birmanie et a activement
encouragé la désescalade de la situation
nous encourageons les pays de la séan à
respecter les principes du consensus et
de la non ingérence dans les affaires
intérieures à rester attachés à l'unité
et la coopération au sein de la famille
de la cia et à promouvoir activement la
désescalade de la situation en birmanie
de la façon dont la séan sait le faire
nous pensons que toute action de la
communauté internationale devrait
contribuer à la stabilité politique et
sociale de la birmanie à sa
réconciliation pacifique et éviter
d'aggraver les conflits et de compliquer
davantage la situation
en plus des violences dans la rue la
répression se déroule aussi dans les
tribunes ont toujours incarcérés en
dessous qui est visé par quatre chefs
d'inculpation dont incitation aux
troubles publics
six journalistes sont également
poursuivis par la justice et encourt
jusqu'à trois ans de prison
les ivoiriens appelés aux urnes samedi
pour les élections législatives pour la
première fois depuis dix ans presque
tous les partis d'opposition sont
représentées parmi eux le front
populaire ivoirien de l'ex président
gbagbo depuis l'ouverture de la campagne
le 26 février dernier
tout semble pour l'instant bien se
passer tous les partis ont appelé à un
scrutin apaisé le 31 octobre dernier en
marge de la présidentielle des violences
avaient éclaté et fait 87 morts et près
de 500 blessés et pour en parler nous
sommes avec louis keumayou président du
club de l'information africaine bonsoir
oui c'est vrai nous merci d'être avec
nous en direct de lomé au togo
quatre mois après donc la présidentielle
houleuse on s'en souvient la situation
s'est elle véritablement apaisées en
côte d'ivoire pour l'instant pour
chacune des formations politiques essaie
d'apaiser le climat dans lequel cette
élection va se dérouler et est tant
mieux parce que cela fait aujourd'hui
plusieurs décennies que la côte d'ivoire
est plongée dans la violence
il faut se souvenir que les premières
violences liées à la démocratie en côte
d'ivoire ont proposé le président
laurent gbagbo qui est aujourd'hui à la
et qui a en belgique après avoir été
transféré à la haye
1 le havre au président actuel le brise
d'alassane dramane ouattara qui est le
bilan de la côte d'ivoire qui à l'époque
le premier ministre deux du du président
houphouët boigny dont on est là d'argent
moments de la vie politique de la côte
d'ivoire qui est comme un grand
changement parce que la plupart de ces
gens là ne sont pas véritable ne sont
pas au premier plan comme on aurait pu
le penser
le président opéré lors d'une élection
présidentielle qu'il a gagné mais sur
laquelle sa légitimité reste encore très
contesté le premier ministre ahmed
bakayoko qui aurait pu porter les
couleurs du parti est en france depuis
plus de deux semaines pour des raisons
médicales
le président gbagbo même s'il est très
présent sa formation politique
aujourd'hui est venu sur le sur la scène
et arrêter la série d'os boycott qui a
su son arrestation et son transfèrement
a fait alliance avec le pdci reprenait
une vraie reconfiguration mais le
problème c'est qu'on a l'impression que
les têtes qui devait porter cette
nouvelle scène politique pour marquer lé
après affrontements des amis de trente
ans que cette jeunesse là ce
renouvellement non alors il ya quand
même une bonne nouvelle c'est que pour
la première fois depuis dix ans les ai
presque tous les partis d'opposition
sont sont représentées c'est un signe de
démocratie on peut dire ça comme ça je
pense que c'est un premier pas vers la
réconciliation
le président aura énormément pêcher sur
le terrain de la réconciliation lors du
stage du mandat cette fois ci il a créé
un ministère dédié à cette cause là et
il est probablement intéressant de noter
que même s'il n'y a pas de liaison de
cause à effet entre la création de ce
ministère et l'ambiance qui a autour des
élections des six têtes tout actuelle il
est ce lui qui n'est pas de violence qui
cale à l'islam élections légistatives
qui sont à venir
alors laurent gbagbo en vous en parlais
tout à l'heure il annoncé dans un
message à ses partisans qu'il rentrera
bientôt en côte d'ivoire on imagine que
c'est pas anodin quelques jours avant
ces législatives
non ce n'est pas anodin parce que cela
permet de galvaniser les troupes cela
permet de resserrer les liens autour de
ce parti car un nouveau souffert d'abord
souffert du fait qu'il n'y avait plus de
sheer à l'appel du parti et à ses
branches de ce qu'on appelait les
balcons rowling
il reconnaissait aucun déchet petit
répit choisis dont pascal affi n'guessan
qui le dernier chef par le game à
seyssinet venu au sein du fbi et qui
aujourd'hui n'ont souhaité je pense que
le veut le plus secret ou le plus clair
de paix dans ma peau c'est que sa
famille politique se reconstitue au dos
d'un seul bloc et non plus autour de
plus de deux ou trois blocs
comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui afin de
vous présenter cette fort qui a gagné a
permis à la côte d'ivoire d'accéder à la
démocratie et qui réussit il vit pendant
une dizaine d'années avant d'être
renversé dans les années 2000 alors
parti de gbagbo qui s'est allié en
rappel avec celui de l'ex-président
auront conan bédié en couille par les
ouïes d'alliance inédite
oui parce que c'est l'alliance qui l'a
fait tomber en 2010 c'est l'année ans de
haricots embêter avec alassane dramane
ouattara qui a permis que le
renversement de voix produite au second
tour alassane ouattara et non pas à leur
encontre
donc légitimement au bruit constant que
c'est une alliance contre nature mais
les hommes politiques et la plupart du
temps les liaisons ne sont pas toujours
des liaisons très logique c'est le cas
aujourd'hui notamment en côte d'ivoire y
avait déjà eu une alliance entre laurent
gbagbo et alassane dramane ouattara
aussi à l'époque où le président
ouattara avait été considéré comme non
ewanje est capable de enfin interdit de
se présenter à la présidentielle est
revenu en trombe républicain qui a été
constitué avec laurent gbagbo
aujourd'hui le noeud le bien est
constituée avec le président henri konan
notés sont les messieurs les adultes
d'alliance ou la scène politique
ivoirienne
ils sont actuellement des patients à des
cultes et merci à louis keumayou
président du club de l'information
africaine la situation au sénégal des
heurts entre la police et des
manifestants ont éclaté au lendemain de
l'arrestation de l'opposant ousman sonko
pour la deuxième journée consécutive de
nombreux jeunes ont manifesté dans les
rues de dakar et plusieurs autres villes
du pays
ils protestent contre le placement en
garde à vue 12 semaines sont co leaders
du parti d'opposition pcf les patriotes
du sénégal pour le travail de quitter la
fraternité qui doit être entendu par un
juge pour des affaires de viol
plusieurs affrontements ont éclaté entre
la police et des groupes étudiants à
l'origine des rassemblements selon les
forces de l'ordre un manifestant aurait
été tué
le sud du pays c'est la fin c'est là
pardon c'est la première fois qu'un pape
se rend en irak une visite historique et
symbolique tel un pèlerin de paix selon
le souverain pontife qui s'est adressé
aux irakiens dans un message vidéo à la
veille de son arrivée il ira à la
rencontre des communautés chrétiennes
kurde et du chef spirituel des chiites
irakiens récit signé clément hospital
derniers préparatifs avant l'arrivée du
souverain pontife en irak
à l'occasion de cette visite historique
les blasons aux couleurs du vatican sont
hissés en haut des poteaux électriques
certaines routes du pays refaite à neuf
non content est jamais été aussi
reluisante ici irakien musulmans comme
chrétiens attendent avec impatience cet
événement c'est une visite historique
on parle d'un chef religieux suivi par
20% de la population mondiale
sa venue veut dire sa rencontre avec le
grand ayatollah ali al-sistani aura un
effet énorme je demande pas françois
d'apporter la sécurité et la paix afin
qu'il n'y ait plus de différence entre
les musulmans et les chrétiens
toute autre confession nous espérons
qu'il y aura la paix et la sécurité
une visite qui relève d'un véritable
casse tête logistique dans un contexte
sécuritaire particulièrement tendu en
trois jours le pape françois va
parcourir plus de 1400 kilomètres par
les airs pour se rendre dans des sites
emblématiques du pays ce qui implique le
survol de certaines zones où se terrent
encore des djihadistes du groupe etat
islamique
un défi auquel s'ajoutent les tensions
entre les deux puissances
agissant en irak l'iran et les états
unis ce mercredi une dizaine de
roquettes se sont abattues sur une base
américaine dans l'ouest du pays
mais pas de quoi bouleverser l'agenda du
vatican des pèlerines
je viens en pèlerin pèlerins pénitents
pour implorer du seigneur pardon et
réconciliation après des années de
guerre et de terrorisme pour demander à
dieu
la consolation des coeurs et la guérison
des blessures je viens en tant que
pèlerin de la paix des packs l'irak qui
doit faire face à des restrictions
sanitaires adopter pour endiguer la
propagation du coronavirus même si le
pape et les responsables ecclésiastiques
ont pu être vaccinés
seul un très faible nombre d'irakiens
ont reçu une dose de sérum le nombre de
places pour les messes sera donc limitée
un confinement sera également décrété
durant toute la visite papale
le souverain pontife qui sera quant à
lui privé de ses bains de foule rituels
et on en vient ce long calvaire pour les
chrétiens d'irak massacrées depuis la
chute de saddam hussein beaucoup ont fui
le pays ne sont plus que 2 % aujourd'hui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
oh
e
et
la cour pénale internationale ouvre une
enquête sur des crimes de guerre
présumés dans les territoires
palestiniens c'est ce qu'a confirmé hier
la procureure générale de l'institution
si cette déclaration était saluée par
l'autorité palestinienne a provoqué un
véritable séisme politique en israël les
etats-unis eux se disent fermement ton
posé l enquête les précisions de jordi
demory le mois dernier la cour pénale
internationale s'était estimé compétente
pour enquêter sur de possibles crimes de
guerre survenue dans les territoires
palestiniens
ce mercredi fatou bensouda la procureur
général de la cpi a ouvert
officiellement le processus
d'investigation
aujourd'hui je confirme l'ouverture par
le bureau du procureur de la cour pénale
internationale d'une enquête sur la
situation en palestine
l'enquète portera sur les crimes
relevant de la compétence de la cour qui
auraient été commis dans la situation
depuis le 13 juin 2014
l'ouverture de l'enquêté a été saluée
par les palestiniens
nous demandons à la cour internationale
de résister à toutes pressions qui
pourraient être exercées sur elle pour
l'empêcher de rendre justice et de punir
les criminels
le hamas est prêt à coopérer avec toute
partie qui peut rendre justice à notre
peuple palestinien et aux victimes et
punir l'occupation pour tous ses crimes
de son côté le porte parole du
département d'état américain a affirmé
son soutien à israël
nous sommes fermement opposés et déçus
par l'annoncé par la procureur de la cpi
d'une enquête sur la situation
palestinienne
nous continuerons à maintenir notre
ferme engagement envers israël et sa
sécurité notamment en nous opposant aux
actions qui cherche à cibler injustement
israël la cpi comme nous l'avons dit
n'est pas compétente en la matière
israël ne fait pas partie de la cpi et
n'a pas consenti à la compétence de la
cour
nous sommes très préoccupés par les
tentatives de la cpi d'exercer sa
juridiction sur le personnalise raéliens
élection au sénat
la décision de l'ouverture de l'enquêté
de la cpi a aussi été condamnée par
l'état hébreu de se
la décision de la cour pénale
internationale d'ouvrir aujourd'hui l'
enquête contre israël pour crimes de
guerre est absurde c'est de
l'antisémitisme non diluée sous couvert
d'hypocrisie sans aucune juridiction
elle a décidé que nos braves soldats qui
prennent toutes les précautions pour
éviter les pertes civiles contre les
pires terroristes du monde qui prennent
délibérément pour cible des civils et se
seraient nos soldats les criminels de
guerre
l'un des axes de l' enquête de la cpi
portera entre autres sur la guerre de
gaza survenu il ya près de sept ans
fatou bensouda estime que des crimes
auraient été commis par les forces
israéliennes
mais l'état hébreu n'est pas le seul
visé par les investigations
le hamas qui contrôle l'enclavé
palestinienne sera aussi dans le viseur
des enquêteurs pour des faits de torture
d'homicides et d'utilisation de
boucliers humains et c'est la fin de
cette émission merci de l'avoir suivi
prochain point complet sur l'actualité
ce sera dans quelques minutes avec
pierre et sa vie et vernon
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous